[Applause]  what does it feel like to be a winner of  the sirius xm top of the country  it feels like  one of your biggest dreams come true  i've admired this program since its  inception and i've tried out and i  really wanted to be a part of it and now  i am and now i'm a winner and i'm just  totally overwhelmed with gratitude  i put my heart and my soul into all this  and  thank you top of the country sirius xm  i've been trying to make my way from the  crowd to the stage for many years and i  won top of the country and i want a  freaking ccma with a recluse for what  the truck  it's absolutely a dream come true what  does it mean to have the support of a  partner like siriusxm  you know it just means a sense of  validity for myself and a sense of just  exposure and visibility and  support from the industry  and that's all i could ever ask for  brought to you by siriusxm's top of the  country visit  topcountry.siriusxm.ca to learn more  about this year's winner